i think it's like a snake you know a
snake knows when it's in striking
distance you know at the end of the day
it's just about competing
hey guys this is alex caruso with
chicago bulls and this is the breakdown
of how i play defense defense is
something i think that you can control
every night
um it's something i've had to hang my
hang my hat on to get into the league i
like stopping other people i like making
people frustrated that that's fun for me
steph's so random with it that my
attention to detail and my sense of
urgency is just always on 100. i'm
really just trying to like stay stay
even with him just kind of shadow him
um because he is so shifty and he really
likes those angles to create separation
so he likes you to open up
he didn't really sell me left
so i was kind of sitting on him coming
back right he's going between tween
tween right there
i kind of open up
but i stayed close enough i stayed up
because i know that he wants to shoot
threes mostly like that's that's kind of
the thing like i'm trying to make him
play off the dribble and get into the
paint i didn't give him a straight angle
and then once he didn't go you know i
kind of beat him to the spot i was close
enough to him still because i'm playing
that three that he crossed over in front
of me i just kind of poked it away and
then once he came back i knew i had
defenders over there on the left as well
once i'm in the late clock situation
with about five seconds left
and he crossed over again and i was just
there so i tapped it away last year
being top 15 and on ball pressure and
then
moving this year into the top ten um i
think it's just you know something i've
continued to harp on just adding to my
game i think holding my opponents under
30 for three is
a lot to do with effort a little bit of
positioning you know making sure that
you're in the right spot guys who are
catch and shoot you know lethal if
you're not there
those are you know certain guys you got
to close out harder to you got to make
sure they put it on the ground you know
maybe versus somebody somebody else that
you're a little lower percentage that
you can close out short two and kind of
contain i noticed starting off that
baseline's open i know i got multiple
guys up top on that first drive um
[Music]
he tries to go downhill so i'm already
anticipating him going baseline cut it
off
chest and then he balls still out there
and i'm close enough so i get a poke on
it and then it's a reset right i know i
know it's i know it's low clock so i'm
sitting on him going back baseline again
uh once he squares up i get back into
him and then he makes a move i'm sitting
on the
sitting on the cross sitting on the
counter because i know i got help middle
i got bodies middle i can send them to
and then in my head you know my internal
clock i'm like all right three
two
one no he has to shoot it she jumped
straight up
couldn't get the shot off the 2.2
turnovers a game that i'm forcing um a
lot of that's coming from on ball
defense but then you know it's a little
bit's navigating down low making sure
that guys are
trailing screens playing the passing
lane bluffing guys when i'm off the ball
to throwing the ball to me or throwing
the ball to a teammate or out of bounds
you know really just trying to mess with
the game trying to trying to keep the
other team off balance because that's
usually when you get turnovers when the
other team is you know thinking a little
more than just playing and reacting
that's usually when you can get mistakes
i know mello's super aggressive i know
he wants to go right
i'm sitting solid i'm square i know
vooch is middle i know we got guys
backsides so if he drives right i got
help there right so i'm anticipating
some type of counter move some type of
change of direction my feet don't really
move right i don't go backwards i just
kind of plant and hold my ground knowing
that
if he comes to me i'm going to try and
get a steal i'm going to try and get
deflection
which i do
and if he goes right
i'm quick enough i'm strong enough to
just funnel him into vooch i don't even
need to cut him off i just need to send
him to the help so he can't get downhill
when i get deflections of guys or i get
guys off balance i look forward to that
because then it fuels me to go out and
play harder the next possession on
defense the behind deflections those are
the ones where guys think they have
layups or guys think they have and you
reach in and get one from behind
everybody knows the straight on where
they go up with it and you just slap
down or slap up i'm adding to my game
i'm getting better at just like i do on
offense where i try to work on my skills
same thing on defense i try to get
different ways to get deflections
forcing turnovers for the team um gets
you out on the break gets easy easy
transition baskets you know anytime you
can try and score in transition that's
the best offense in the league against
the knicks so i'm guarding julius
initially i'm square the sideline that's
how they teach you feet parallel to the
sideline but that we're coming from the
top to double team so
i open up just a little bit but i'm just
shading them towards where those coming
from
and my only job right there is don't let
them spin baseline because if he spends
baseline we have nobody to help right
tony bradley's
boxing nerlens noel's cut out
zach's rotating to the first pass
and demar is playing two on the back
side so if he spins baseline you can see
the paint's wide open he's gonna have a
layup so for me it's just about keeping
the middle and from there we just trust
our rotations the nba chord optics
metrics help show some more impact than
than the traditional stats steals and
blocks are good even if you track
charges now but being able to quantify
you know an impact on on the defensive
end more so than just did that guy take
the ball away or did he get a cool block
into the stands it's really just helped
show the value of you know guys like me
around the league that do a lot on the
defensive end thanks for watching this
was the breakdown and just remember if
you're trying to get on the court you
got to learn how to play defense